- The number one reason I push patience
is 'cause patience will give
you the air cover to take risk.
If you realize how,
do you know what I wish
for all of you 25 year olds in here?
That you knew how long you'd feel at 40.
'Cause 40's fucking old to you,
I was just there
and news alert, you're gonna
kind of feel exactly the same.
And when you understand that,
and then once you go insular,
one of the reasons maybe
I've never had a mentor
is 'cause I don't value
anybody else's opinion
more than my own.
And it's a very,
and I'll tell you why that's important,
because if I lose, then I deserve it.
Because then if I win, I deserve it.
But the way to really eliminate fear
is by not giving a fuck
about anybody's opinion.
My losses are mine.
I'll deal with them myself.
I don't need your two cents,
you're losing plenty on your own.
That, patience and inner voice,
makes you unbeatable.
It's crazy how I feel my whole life,
never had peer pressure,
never did anything, anything, ever, ever
that I didn't want to do
because I just didn't value
somebody else's opinion over mine.
And that comes from good
parenting, circumstance, DNA,
a million fucking things.
I don't know how to teach that.
What I'm just trying to do
is I'm trying to become,
in a weird way I like being popular
because I become your courage.
I think the most flattering thing
that's happening to me in my life
is I'm becoming people's courage
because when they take risk
and they take ridicule,
they point to me.
And I tell their parents
to go fuck themselves.
And that's a very, very, very interesting,
if you look, I don't know how deep
any of you are in my content,
I know you are John,
that is what I'm doing,
and it's a very good feeling,
I feel very happy
'cause I think I'm bringing people value
because let me tell you what's
way more scary than failure,
regret,
you just don't know it yet.
Regret is fucking poison
and you start feeling it
when you can't do anything about it.
And I have a funny feeling when you're 65,
you don't feel that
much different than 40,
much different than 25.
The problem is you're
starting to run out of time.
Got it?
But I agree with you,
the relationship with parenting
and the conservative nature of the culture
leads to a lot of that
which is too bad
because you think you're
doing your parents a favor
by appeasing them
but later in life you're
gonna really be mad at them
and resent them
and it's not gonna play out.
(gentle music)